On October 4th, 2020, epidemiologists from
Harvard, Oxford, and Stanford, authored
The Great Barrington Declaration.
Because of “grave concerns about the damaging physical and mental health impacts
of the prevailing COVID-19 policies,” they argued that all COVID-19 lockdowns should end.
Instead, we should adopt a strategy they call “Focused Protection,”
which is aimed at protecting elderly and vulnerable populations
while allowing everyone else to resume normal life.
The proponents of Focused Protection say it’s the most compassionate approach
“to minimize mortality and social harm until we reach herd immunity,”
which is the goal of all COVID-19 mitigation strategies.
This is the saner approach, the more moral approach, the more scientifically based approach.
Critics of the Declaration issued a counter memorandum stating that,
“Any pandemic management strategy relying upon immunity from natural infections for COVID-19 is flawed...
Uncontrolled transmission in younger people risks significant morbidity and mortality across the whole population.”
Should the Coronavirus lockdowns be lifted and replaced
with a targeted strategy that protects the old and other high-risk groups?
That was the subject of an online Soho Forum Debate on Sunday December 13th.
It featured Martin Kulldorff, a Harvard biostatistician and epidemiologist
and co-author of the Great Barrington Declaration
versusAndrew Noymer, an associate professor of Population Health and Disease Prevention
at University of California, Irvine, who signed the so-called John Snow Memorandum written in response.
Here’s Martin Kulldorf and Andrew Noymer in an online debate
moderated by Soho Forum Director Gene Epstein.